many Nigerians say these elections could
not be happening at a more critical time
in the race to choose the president vice
president as well as members of the
Senate and House of Representatives the
stakes are extremely high these two
people out there are very hungry there
is no cash
will have most time does not take care
of our salaries
throughout the capital people have a
long wait to get fuel and it takes even
longer to get money
that's because of a rushed redesign of
the national currency and a botched
rollout of the new banknotes
18 candidates are campaigning for the
presidency but opinion polls suggest
only three have a chance of winning
Nigeria has more than 93 million
registered voters and about 40 percent
of them are under the age of 35. that's
why many here believe the youth may play
a pivotal role in the outcome
hamzat lawal is among a new generation
of activists speaking out against
corruption in Nigeria and promoting good
governance
today we have a
100 million people that are very poor
unemployment over 30 percent
unemployment rate one of the highest
ever he believes many of the economic
problems are a result of growing
insecurity in the country today we've
lost for indirect investment because the
Nigerian government cannot guarantee
safety of lives of the property we move
from not only Boko Haram now to also you
know successionists in the Southeast and
we have Band-Aids in the village of
rugan madaki on the outskirts of Abuja
Mercy Daniels Works in a plumbing shop
and says she hopes the ballots will go
smoothly I want the elections to be fair
it should be fair and the should look in
violence actually
[Music]
nearby shop owner onion okoli worries
whether her son and daughter will be
able to get the education they need
we are so far a lot in this Nigerian I
pray that we thought after this election
May everything turn around
in a country where so many people are
hoping for change they're also
apprehensive about what these elections
will bring
Abuja